we welcome you here at 6 30 with
developing news good morning to you i'm
alex backus
i'm john langler so we are following
this developing story at the federal
courthouse in downtown las vegas
and as we've told you about all morning
police have been investigating a
suspicious item there bianca holman live
on scene with the very latest good
morning bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
we're at the corner of 7th and clark and
for several hours here these areas were
blocked off but you can see now the
roads are back open
but off in the distance you can see
they're still flashing lights so metro
is still on scene
they are still on property there at the
federal courthouse but the roads
surrounding it are back open
now metro's bomb squad they were on
scene assessing the suspicious item that
was left in front of the federal
courthouse
this all came into our newsroom around 3
a.m this morning
and these are situations that of course
the police takes very seriously so they
quickly set up a perimeter around the
courthouse and
there were several road closures in the
area now we also know that there is a
trump rally that is scheduled to start
at sahara and then end up here at the
federal courthouse
and it seems as if now that the roads
are open we're not quite sure if that's
going to still be their end point
but again once we learn more updates
about what the suspicious package was if
it was hazardous we will continue to
keep you all updated
throughout the morning on our twitter
feed and on air but as of right now
the area around the federal courthouse
is back open back to you guys in the
studio
all right bianca thanks for following
that for us